um all right we're go over the single
Pivot Point again you don't you never
want to
turn with two feet
never so like
uh if you doing the sh
n you'll see here and then they'll do
two
feet no this is dra
okay always have to single Pivot Point
single Pivot Point single Pivot
Point single Pivot
Point double
pivot single PIV
single
pivot single
pivot okay let's try that for real just
from the Sho
nugget
okay okay so I wasn't clear this isn't
how to do sh nag
Ura I don't do it like this okay but
ferites do so ferites ferites do their
double
pivot okay okay I don't do
that so I this is a
drill not she not get rid
of so I'm going to single pivot rotation
has stopped there's no more rotation
when I step back I just step back and
now I have to bring her into position
that's what I do there then I shift
single pivot
again so just a drill on single pivot
okay Enter single
pivot step back straight
thigh bring her with you shift your
weight
back
then shift forward single pivot
rotation out movement is straight
back okay let's
try all right so let's define double
pivot and double
pivot obviously when you use both feet
to rotate that's going to be double
pivot so
if I go here and then both feet turn
that's a double
pivot but let's define it
kinesiologic double pivot is any time I
rotate and my line of gravity is in the
middle of my basis support
elements so my line of gravity is a
perpendicular line traveling from my
center of
gravity to the
ground so when you turn on both
feet your line of gravity is in the keep
your R please your line of gravity is in
the middle that's what makes it double
pivot
okay you're double pivoting on the first
move so when you
turn you're on both feet the line of
gravity
is in the middle so your first turn on
you is the double
pivot you have to shift your weight onto
one leg you can go back or you can go
forward but you always
turn on one leg can you see how you're
doing
that not two
leg there times here and then I go
forward I'm on that leg
in this move I enter and that's when I
shift and that's when I turn I'm on the
other
leg the line of gravity is over that
foot which is why this foot can slide
back and
forth stay in place whatever there's no
weight on it I'm on one
foot so the line of gravity is on that
foot I step back
I reset the
drill I'm going to move again onto that
foot and that's where I
turn and again I'm on that foot with the
line of
gravity so we do the
drill e meee shift onto the front foot
all is
there step back no rotation you see no
rotation you don't want to turn with the
line of gravity between your feet you
kind of linearly move that's what I did
there
boom shift
rotate boom all rotation done then line
of gravity can go in the
middle shift
turn okay try it again a very common
thing is you use one foot to turn the
other foot that's why people double
pivot so here you
are it's going to look the
same but you're going to turn you're
going to turn this foot you're going to
use this foot to turn that foot that's a
double pivot so all all your weight is
going to go on to this foot there's
nothing on this foot and that's where
this foot turn this
foot
off off
turn boom take weight off of that
foot
turn Boom turn
Boom
turn
turn Boom turn okay that's closer to it
then here double pivot cosmetically
shift
W boom
off don't push into the
turn Boom
turn okay try
to there's two reasons why you want to
single pivot not double pivot and
they're interrelated
okay um the first one
is I am going
to uh
change the cross Vector at which and
rotation happens so for
example if we're here and I pivot on
both
feet
the grip in relation to where my Center
is I am going to always be on the front
side of this of the grip so I have this
kind of pull to what I'm
doing this way
or I move my hand to here it's still
it's there on my Center my hand but
she's still way over there on that side
and it turns into a pool about there you
feel that
yes and when I single point pivot I get
to the other side of that so let's
look
obviously we'll we'll mark my elbow okay
in my Y
Line it is on this
side the east side of the grip she is
completely on the west side of the
grip when I shift my
weight all of a sudden my elbow is on
the other side of the grip my shoulders
on the other side of the grid so I'm
pivoting with more of a
push than the
pull more of a
push if she throws a
strike
here and I go here and i t con does you
can see the deviation is happening over
here
on the other one I get to the other side
the deviation is happening over
here so i t con I'm in the
back as opposed
to not quite
that so what I'm doing here with a
single point pivot is I'm moving to from
the negative side of the circle to the
positive side of the circle in my angle
deviation okay and that changes my
energy into a pushing energy versus a
pulling energy and that is important for
the second point when you use a pulling
energy on a rotation eventually that
pulling energy the oppos the equal and
opposite reaction is going to cut
through the shikaku of your stance of
your double pivot stance and you're
going to feel very very
weak um you're going to feel unable to
hold your balance against resistance now
this problem is neutralized by the
fedorite UK who will never pull on you
okay but every once in a while you still
see them mess up and you see the nogget
lose their balance okay
so if she's
doing um if she's going to do the double
pivot 10 con and you do that yeah you
never know that just swing your foot
around that one this is very common okay
do it again that okay this is this is
what Tenon is for everyone in the
fedorite world so R 10 con is she has to
shift her weight onto here all the
rotation happens there and then this is
a tactical repositioning of one's person
the other one the line of gravity is in
the middle of the feet as they swing
around this way that's a double pivot
okay so if
she if if I have uh let's do the r
version okay so she's going to single
pivot and try to get as much as she can
on the other side of that Circle so she
can push this hand forward and I'm going
to try to pull her I'm trying to pull
her this way okay she got some pull in
there and there should be no pull in
there okay so this is why I was saying
you were double pivoting okay so here
here's what it is um you start pulling
on me you see that cuz my line of
gravity here that's the pull so when you
pull on me pull back on me I can't turn
do you see that if I push here and you
pull back on me it doesn't it's not me
going this way way cuz we turning that
way you
see so let's watch the difference I'll
try it again and I don't know what angle
is going to show it okay because my Mass
is always on the negative side of the
circle in the double
pivot you going
straight is
here right
there if I change that to a pull you
going back
eventually I am fighting that do you see
that and I can't turn and the more I
take this
away pull the more I lose that Integrity
on the other one there's no pull ability
you see and i t con into free space okay
there's no
rotation that I'm using
with my line of gravity in between my
two feet okay so let's see if we can
clean you up you got to get completely
to the other side and on one foot so you
got to step over
here turn all the way don't don't try to
pull me you want to go you want to go
push me you want to push me not pull
me do it please
you're trying to pull
me your arms going to come in because
this is an outward spiral
movement
okay good there's no there's no there's
no I fall into a void okay now let's do
the other one first let me see you do
the other one go
yes and you'll
feel as you start to go you're going to
feel it right here you see okay and the
more you separate your feet into the ten
conon the more you can't do it okay so
if we were doing
Shon you can grip and you do that other
Tenon the wrong ten con here you're
never going to get
it okay and every time you try to pull
me if I'm just bigger than you you try
to pull
me not going to get it you get weaker
you see okay so that's what we're
accomplishing or getting rid of
when we never do that okay I've always
going to single pivot so in the drill
that we were doing in the sh naget prep
I don't want to go like that because
that's where the pulling energy her
pulling is cutting through my base right
here it's no different than if she
grabbed my collar and pulled me where I
had no
base that's the same thing here when you
double pivot instead I go
under
H boom we're now in our sh net prep
drill so I can enter Then
single other side
boom
enter boom
single other
side
Bo boom
wrong
right right
wrong okay let's do this she